and you know in our early 20s if you'd
said hey will you sing the song we kind
of be like roller I was like yeah sure
you know but now I'm actually excited to
play it for fans because I know what a
great reaction it gets yeah and we've
kind of revamped it in this new way so
it's actually really cool what did you
think when that got a whole new life
on its own I mean we were very surprised
like we were not on Tick Tock at that
point in time in some ways did it feel
like you took the song back yeah kind of
I mean it was always ours but it but it
you know those songs those kind of songs
can date a little bit you know it's like
heavy electronic synth pop early 2000s
which is always around I guess but yeah
it needed a redo you know we sound Young
on it because we are our vocals there's
like a lot of auto-tune on it where like
I'll listen to it now and just be like
wow that's that's a choice because that
was such a choice but it was that was in
that was like a style